imagine how amazing it would be if they
choose ocasio-cortez
just to see the AOC Trump debates uh
don't don't tease me like that don't
cheat that would be I'll just get a
comment I'll see her tomorrow
uh it would be just beautiful I'm not
saying anything but I'm saying it'll be
a sight to behold do you mind you have
to do that more people are talking about
Michelle Obama uh today no yeah yeah
yeah and I think Michelle Obama could
she could be one of those she's going to
do it for the good of the country so to
speak she'll be one of those that says I
really don't want to and my husband
doesn't want me to but I have to for the
good of the country you could see her
jump in that that would be a little
scary because I'm concerned about the
electorate and how they vote but we did
get some hope though a couple weeks ago
did we not with with the crime that
we're seeing across our country get rid
of that nut job in Chicago that light
foot oh see they're not just horrible
you see the reporters say get the hell
out of this city